so it didn't really occur to me in a way
and so when I did
Bill and Ted Like Lost Boys you know was
like mini Fame right because when you
got that and it came out were people
starting to recognize you even the I
don't know if you talked about this with
key French oh yeah I'll listen to that
yeah you didn't but when I did lost boys
and they're probably too modest to talk
about this but when I did Lost Boys
it was a little different it was like a
bigger production than anything else I'd
kind of encountered and it felt special
going in
um and I know Kiefer I'm I know Kiefer
and Jason felt the same way
um it was just because of Joel because
of Marion Doherty because of Warner
Brothers I felt like wow I'm part of
something a little bigger than anything
I've experienced it was a small part so
I didn't think I was going to be famous
off of that role I didn't have any idea
the film was going to have the legs that
it's had
um but it but it felt special you know
like I'm sure Smallville was the same
it's part of something that feels like
this is good when you get a break you
kind of know it's a break yeah you know
that feeling like you're kind of like oh
this is different this is like not the
same [ __ ] that I've experienced before
um and so you know your life's going to
change in some little way yeah uh and I
just knew it and uh yeah me too I feel
like most the time you're like going I I
don't know I hope this is good yes I I
hope I hope it turns out really yeah
great I hope this is but when you're in
something that you sort of innately
you're like I just know this is good
yeah it's a shift right it's weird it's
weird shift yeah wow I'm on something
that people will see yeah and it's not
here I mean for me it wasn't like uh I'm
so great or anything it was just like
you're like you've been invited onto a
bus or a train that's just riding on a
on a really sweet track and you just
know it yeah and uh so I kind of knew it
with lost boys that that that that was
kind of cool but I wasn't gonna get
famous I mean I was gonna have like you
know people like on the subway going yo
Lost Boy right like that was gonna
happen right
foreign